[music]
[applause]
set for
and so this is the second part of my presentation
and as I said before .
we talked about the myths associated with the
study of foreign languages ​​out and had
made of principles of chess principles
of black
and now I want to tell you about the methods of
learning languages ​​and reject other
principles of how to learn them.
the first most important question is whether we can
learn a foreign language as well as a
child masters the language to we are now
looking for likes tester and the first sentence is the
usual common we need
to learn the language just like a child learns it
give hold the way
it is called the natural way of
mastering ghede
and this is a fact that  it is impossible to argue
that children learn languages ​​well in hong kong
need the people the sun people troll
but the wrong conclusion that some
people can draw from this is i
feel like i will sex this is such a principle
if i start learning a language like a
child does, i will get good
the result is lamy
post shame and geralda conditions in
which his wife
I will start by saying that the conditions in
which children learn a language and adults
learn a language are different conditions for she-
wolves down one life is like a doll in
fine integers first of all children
learn only one  he doesn’t
have a language they don’t have a second language which
affects their mastery of this  I will learn the original
first language
and they have no other choice as she
said they need to learn the language of 30 and
the main difference is when you
master your first native language
it is the result of your life of the life
process it is not a conscious choice but
not enough of it south of the whole movie
because usually  when you don't have a choice you
can't make the wrong choice
ultimate tables and play
daikin she's an adult she can really
make the wrong choices choose
the wrong learning methods for herself and as a
result give up learning the language even
our father is gone yes but that doesn't
mean at all that children learn the language
faster and  better ask them apples
in English there is an expression when
we say that you are comparing apples and
oranges minsk this means that you are
comparing things that are completely unrelated
tales pets
and this is the same case when we are trying to
compare how children learn a language and how
an adult learns a language  and bull air race
account and
up to 7000 it seems to me that  a fair
comparison can only be made under the
same conditions,
it’s true that adults have
some shortcomings, but we do
n’t have some advantages that
children have,
but we can’t say that we lose very much
to children nikitovich
let’s see how children learn the language
in which  conditions in
first of all is in the family, as
richard said,
and this means that the child is surrounded by the tongue from the
very moment of his birth,
he also got enough sleep, and what does this mean, it
means that in this there is the love of the father's mother
play time but also there is play there is
play time and found in this process
there is a natural curiosity to
learn about the world a place to hide, but in
fact, these psychological
factors play a huge role in learning the
language of
s.d.  bulgar school and then we all go to
school and school will ann-sofie for HIV
or full contact and at school we begin to
master a second language
already in a formal environment of faces we
communicate with our classmates see
our mistakes are corrected by the teacher he you
sleep and when we  talking and when we
write
gold is gone and so language learning is
also the result of communication
interaction with your classmates
and with other people who are learning a
foreign language you see very well and also we
all love to watch movies
listen to the radio and listen to music and spend
more time
and don't even pay attention to  this is attention we
listen to language
anesthesia and orphans for a huge part of our life besides we have many
friends with abs
all this helps us to learn the language when
we are children videos but if we count
and 365 days a year
lassa potentiates
and teaches let's say we take the example of an
18 year old
compose a child and so multiply three starset 5 by 18 years and
plus by 24 hours because our brain
learns the language even when we sleep  as
speaking and as a result, we get 78
thousand eight hundred and forty hours of reading,
listening, speaking writing and living the
language for asus, that is, language acquisition
occurs as an integral process and
stretched over a long long period of
time on the street can be
seen such a doll complicated and now
let's  look at the conditions in which
adults learn languages ​​infom first of
all we have interferences from our
native language there are overlaps or
interferences
expansions what it means we have
an overlay grammar
overlay pronunciation syntax and so
on except where children are actually
more curious than we adults  we still
retain a share of the curiosity of adult
life, but not like children
5x and just like I said before,
adults may have a fear of
speaking fear of judgment fear of making
mistakes in speech and fijaros
they are afraid of judgment of people around
likes I'm in your los and also ours  life
there are other factors we have less time
insurance of  the executive committee we are not in an
environment in which this one is learning the
language constantly sounds in chop seraph
black and nothing as a rule we are busy we
have a lot of other things we have
work in general there are many other things in
life without the basic elements that companies
that big ass  on tv
that is, what does it mean to compare the process of
learning a language by a child and adults is
almost impossible because the conditions are
different,
primarily because we have
internal psychological factors
interference as a factor that I have already
named when you learn your first
natural language, this language does not overlap with you
does not mix with another
language Hindus are funny to the beginning to be
something from the regiment besides your language
has a very strong emotional
charge it is very emotionally
connected place which it show
and this has a huge role in the country of the cops
and besides these internal
psychological factors there are also
external ones  environment factor factors i took the
floor and blizzard smilein ncr  and news
if, for example, one of you goes
to live in italy and lives there for 18
years hill yulyasha sleeps and in
these 18 years you will hear the language you
will speak the language of
the school game you will go to school
when you make mistakes you will be
corrected  and fell and fifa is caught
if you completely go through this path of an
18-year-old teenager and they show I am sure
that you will speak the language
quite well hiv I will swim
you may not reach the level of native
speech proficiency
but you will reach a very high level
of language proficiency that will allow  you
do whatever you want in this language
show how we learn a second language first of
all most of us call
foreign language staying in our
home country we don't move another
cis country dollar index comfort your
question is how to master a foreign
language
being an independent learner and staying
with  at home like I said before the
bad news is that we don't have
all the benefits that
kept the children super only but there is also good
news from les because we as
adults have our own advantages
when we start doing something
whatever we start doing
I think it is important to start with the right
attitude, start with the right
attitude and you need to do
right choices
dollars people in sales office with
and without on the internet so many people
ask what method of learning a
foreign language is the best form of
task for you did not enter from 4s white
lies the fact is that the problem is that the search for an
objective
super effective method that will
suit everyone is meaningless to you  explo
him
let me explain why you think you are
doing no one test meter the reason
why there is no
best way to beach view
is that each of you
lauren became nfl i.e.  each of you has
your own way of
learning and your own tastes laryngitis sum
what is good for me my judge at night
may not suit you trial and
error process and less of it from youtube s7 and
beijing this means you have to try
and find for yourself what works
best for you  from the very beginning the most important
principle from the very beginning of learning a language is to
understand what you like
what suits you and even before I
move on to the methods let me
tell you all the most basic cognitive
principles first and very important this
attitude is
very important to have a positive attitude to
this process positions are correct
a positive attitude and to treat the
process of learning a language as something
fun and something simple, and nuts
Oleg Ivanovich fought people, and it’s
also very important to treat not just
the language itself, but the people from the TSN capsule,
and as I said, the psychological
factor
your image is very important in alchemy, and it is also important for us to
know our limits, we are all people with you, we
all do  mistakes and a branch of the world but
if we know that we have the
limitations of the iphone it can
turn into our strength
make that creature next create time
he inflicted the publisher
one of the most common
excuses for people is when they
say I don't have time to learn a
foreign language  language in intel and you have la
manga slasher site there's not a way of
time and resistor and meiko use with
quintilian roman
rhetoric said that it is wrong
to say that we don't have time to
say correctly that we use it wrong
likes and I think he was right
because  he we always find time to
do what we like then our cloak
kill
then the next question is how to create
the necessary time for yourself could sender if
you look at this little thing
here from you what parable yours will live
how you know this portable device
from your head  better files is a real
revolution in the world of
learning foreign languages ​​you then use
because you can use  this
device is anywhere at any time
but of course it is important to want to
use it and you can use it
when you go somewhere, drive a car to
wash dishes and even shopping in a
store.
what does it mean to
be successful and in a single you need
to learn every day special and wreaths from
this maybe even 2 times a day 7 years
old legend and rings & fils
for example you can spend 30 minutes
devoting 30 minutes to learning a language
when you feel free when
you feel like when you have
energy for example when you are not working
on weekends
timecode half your fingers and if you are
tired you don’t have much energy then you
can use your passive time
for passive study for example listening to
recordings
she is another one of are  back to fly they are
someone's soup model on horseback and
I just re-read these examples when you go somewhere
do shopping wash the dishes
eg  o symbol, the great advantage of this
principle is that training daily publishes you a
free to play game guide for making up
what this way allows you to
feed your brain constantly
keep it in the form of information you know
your but small for lance to be a small chance in
fomich the next very important moment is ours
the brain is better at assimilating small pieces of
information
people may think that if
they spend 10 hours every day studying a
language, it is better
than spending 30 minutes a day fighting just
pan juma that intu en santa
but when you spend too much
time doing something your love can  send
us down
your level of concentration is decreasing show
your game calculate the url about it lot
i.e. you will get the impression that you
are studying very hard with a bucket of stone and
chips but you are studying inefficiently you
don't mind and also if you study in
small pieces all the time you don't  you
burn do not burn out and what does it mean to
burn out you will not get sick of this
language
saving state the people may and here e  then
burnout is a fairly
common mistake that people
make
in the tundra pillar
next principle is what you read
what you study you should be
able to understand it could be
digested murder conspiracy and
besides it should be interesting
next important principle you need
diversify your work without jesus mc
because if you constantly do the
same thing, far from the collection, it
becomes boring with her, but you stand like this,
for example, if you have a text in front of you,
they are warm days
on October 2, you are far from controversy and you
constantly read read the text and
learn a language through reading sooner or
later it becomes boring if you
consider the text a piece of information and
besides if you have an
audio recording for this text on a new one you can not
just read the text bat officer if you
think about it you rushed into it
invest
you can also read the text  and listen to
it at the same time you then just you can
just listen to it
or read this  text aloud
sleeping and
usals singing get out of that street and you
can even start talking to
yourself use
things the words that you saw in the
text
that is important not only how much you
work how much you do
but how exactly you do it details  the
advantage is that
it is very easy to read and listen at the same time,
anyone can do it ongoing chinchin
UAH 6
and when you vary your activities you
switch from one activity
to another you remain interested
you have a variety and sciences schools in
double
in all schools  world and chimes a foreign
language is a compulsory subject that you
should study why we are considered to be
sponsoring well that the time factory series
end blowing huskies she trembles subject old
and unfortunately in most schools this is
substantively treated as one of the
subjects that need to be studied of the
beginning  of the piece to beat on a
plate a new number,
well, as I said in the language, you need to ovl  to put
it on could not be impossible to learn
from another important parameter is
memorization the
best campaign it is generally accepted that
memorizing something by heart is a good
thing for example, they are given the task of learning
poems poems by heart
silent block sa samp exe the
doctor yourself but when we speak the language
it is  it looks like we use
different cubes to
build a wall of
your buy from these cubes and therefore we produce
something new, in fact, we learn
when we repeat something, something varies
with show-offs and when we interact with
content with meaning with content  so that
with an ax I bark for a long time the context and the conclusion of what
words and grammar we study from
the fixation context is an honor and if you
think about it this is how
children learn or the transition we learn by repeating
something but does not memorize and memorize
from the ant account another important factor
is motivation  and fear and beat the roof of all
ours if you have a beautiful ferrari you
don't have gasoline like it's like you don't have a
ferrari
most l  people quit learning a
foreign language because they don’t
know how to maintain their interest and their
motivation will decrease with timur you’ll get out als an
easy way to solve this problem is to
motivate yourself with logic new mansu himself
old for example you can think about what
you can do as a result of at
least a few months  learning a
language you can travel all over the
world if you know languages
it will be easier for you to travel it will be easier for you
i think of the people
you can talk to people you can
read interesting books about
touring this country in their language you think
and she's a movie and  all I see you can
watch interesting documentaries
or feature films files
and before for romantics you can even
meet your love and of course what is
very important in life make friends
come on that is every time you
start your work on learning a language
think about what it is  you will
be allowed to do in life
angel live
deutch this means that language de  Languages
can really change our life and my life
languages ​​have changed the analogue of the principle the following
principle is an action I pay them when we
speak a language this is an art of
imperfection and each of us tried
to speak the language and at the beginning
it was difficult for each of us we something  then they
muttered something and each of
us, of course, made mistakes made
mistakes when he tried to express his ideas
shield and sword
lara instead of xp photo of their successes.
the active actually make a
lot of mistakes before they get the hang of the
language start speaking well after
the limits and now i you need to recognize
your limitations and know wall that to
do something well and force of the
diode full first you need to do
it  bad and my spears oh fine life so
hold fast access
in my life we ​​experience I meet
many more perfectionists of
ideas who want to speak the language of
ideally from the very beginning icing
spent went and
but Kutsenko dreamed of the face of a chair and I think
that perfectionism is not a good thing
when we  talking about learning the language salon
speaking people have to feel varey and
when we are already moving on to
talking to people we should
feel ready they are hillary and when we
feel that we are ready staples you
can for example start talking to
yourself and some people can  to think
that you completely survived and the amount if he
sees you walking down the street and talking
to yourself frixio bows in sh  oh but
i actually found out that a lot of
us do it like when we take a
shower and speaking show is not that it's
not a
crazy  this is a very
effective way to
iphone dock porn online and as I
said before we can always find a
partner either on the internet or in
real life you with whom we can
interact we can exchange
our language for his language ax line
gives consist on his language in the world  case of
responding to something people
and what is the conclusion language is a
communication tool and we can
improve it when we use it
in communication with other people or just by
users and we bring it to perfection
through the use of don't speak your
speaker now as a result of the fact that  we
do become automatic skills
we don't think
about what we do when we speak Russian
we just talk about
and this does not apply  this applies only to our
native language
and to other languages ​​​​that
we want to learn, we tried yu.
so there is no beaten path to
language proficiency but there is your own
way less examples from eight
and so on.  this means that when we need to get from
point a to point b, the sun has a
completely different trajectory how to
get there and the proof of this is
that me and richard, if you call it an
example, we studied languages ​​in completely
different ways and nevertheless, I think
at least I hope that  we were both
good at stone and stadiums.
these files are your own don't be that there is the
following what i wanted to say is that
you need to find your own way
dis-moi slips sleep and found to be
killed so this chart reflects my
experience of learning languages ​​it's not some kind of
universal chart but it's something  what
happens to me when I learn a
language this axis denotes time
and this is an efficiency parameter which in
turn also depends on time
layer what happens at the very beginning we
start learning a language slowly
oh pissing
this is
the pace that I choose for myself I
make a decision  you started to learn a language
slowly because this language is
unknown but when you
get a sense of the language in this process it
becomes a little more familiar to
you on the principle of play and then something
amazing happens in the mind in the
brain you want people hold it is any point
people call  This .  epiffani
in english
in general it is that moment when you have
a sense of the language and this
feeling it is present in your
mind you have the feeling that you can
use the language one wil my wife and
once that happens you can learn
much faster just by using the language
even  not realizing what you learn
through and this means that the use of the
language becomes automatic
it becomes an automatic
thought process and table and and but
if each phase is dismantled at the beginning the language is
completely unknown to us
and the advice that I can give I have already called
every day work a little
boxing teaches  determine the content
how to learn a language on what content on
what content this can be
followed by consecutive lessons of
yours my method that i use i
use
bilingual packages for example when i
studied russian
your oh oh sex machines if i wanted to
learn russian i would definitely
have  there would be texts in Russian and
it would be their correspondence  either in Italian
or in some other language, Andrews was in a hurry, the
cik was not
heard and then
I use a special technique
called bilingual translation gave spain
games this method allows me to
isolate information to keep it in
my head
my principle is that first you need to work
efficiently  and name is all of the lights
out
and my goal in this first step is
to create a foundation for further
language learning oohh you want a piece of
me more or measures when you already have a
solid foundation in the language the
use of the language becomes a bit
more automatic historically and
when this happens you no longer think
about the language, you just use it and
baltics alpha interiors and at this phase,
if we talk about content, I myself
create man monolingual bilingual text
and pain studios a year chance leshchenko and
alsu will be latma
from methods I continue to use
bilingual translation  but besides that, I
'm starting to read a lot, and here the principle is already
not only quality  in but also the number and
such of killed .
and nerfed and the point is to build in your
head the basis of this language one
which
and when you reach a certain
level the language becomes very
familiar to you again on it and this
means that you can do a lot
to learn the language without even thinking
about it  and time ceases to be a
problem and started and this is the phase in
which we already use TV
documentaries books movies
films and most obviously native speakers
because communication in learning a language is
very important
its simple to me now possible so what
else and what method am I creating here
build their own environment for themselves
in which I can use this language as much as possible
domain costs chaos and this means that in
this phase I use the language of the
gods constantly subtract 6 from 9
it dislike flanges and my goal at this
stage of course it is ambitious is to reach the
level of native speakers  flexibility native
speaker he has that plan well of course
learning never stops we
constantly have  we are trying to squeeze out the
facts of the gatekeepers’ own fund of the doors
why my system is effective I understood
it later
Dorian saw the principle is
that this system respects the
paretto principle less yun san te does not beat it
means you learn something a little
learn it is good from a psychiatrist potapych
considered  and rebound and this little
effort allows you to learn to master the
rest of the language the rest of the
remaining eight eighty
percent date and
whitehall python 3 principles so this
principle is called 20 by 80
which is not language learning is not a
linear process
donilon audio friend asics from white sands
dean nw
it’s impossible to just learn all the
colors first and then everything else into some
other category from the zone no
sparkles soar there is a kitty rake you
assimilate the material that surrounds you
quite chaotically and the process of learning the
language is progressive non-linear that moment is
very burning time ai dont veist essence
interface and a good aspect of my method
is what changes from  over time,
I don’t use the same methods and what’s
more important, it’s constant consistent with
use of consistency, that is, I
use the principle of constancy, I study the
language every day as soon as I started
learning it and the next one, my method takes into account
my way of learning
adapts to that  how i learn and this
method is diverse because i
use different approaches they are the only one
for me it is very fun i like it very
much and fan that is my conclusion what
language learning is not difficult it can be a
fun process martin riis
4d old people very if the next what you
it is important to remember that mastering a language
can change your life
ricambi dan and phenol and besides you
can master a language if you know how
to do it
next the
internet has really revolutionized and
changed the way we can learn
and the last thing I wanted to say is
happy learning languages
thank you
[  music]
[applause]